intersections unions I'm still going to
deal with these same two inequalities
but instead of putting an end in between
I'm going to put the word or so look
like this now what did this mean if I
say to you
yeah we're earning paper get definite
lovers or supreme other minified meat
lovers for supreme will I be happy if
you come back with supreme I will
because that was one of the options that
I waited for you right whereas if I said
meat lovers and supreme I'm expected to
bring two pieces otherwise you can get
right so this means you need both of
them this means you know what eating's
got one I don't really care about the
other that's fine one is the not super
okay so I'm going to say union of
regions doesn't mean necessarily both at
the same time satisfying just one is
sufficient and I should point out we've
got tuna quality tea we're consuming
together you might as well first act if
you know it we've got two here that
we're considering together you could
have three or four and you would still
use the same logic okay
just like last island draw the
boundaries
[Music]
okay now this is a lot easier than what
we had before it's lower than what we
have before you don't even really have
to think too much you just have to say
everything that you shaded before
because if i satisfy one of them then
I'm happy it doesn't matter whether it
satisfies the other Amazon so I'm going
to show you everything below the
straight line that was part of the
original region so that's that's good
that satisfies water food namely this
one and I'm also going to shade
everything above the product there you
go now we'll know that just like in the
original the parabola was included so
therefore the probability included here
decimal so I'll go ahead yes question
you mean like this pipe down now
strictly speaking notes because what I
want is where is the region shader where
is it not and without a bubble boy this
lines don't matter but I don't think see
any reason to not afford because torie
wipers expert it's a lot easier if you
should go home experts closed ah so we
haven't quite finished yet right I've
got all the right shading bits but just
like here there are points of
intersection which matter right there
are same ones that we had before so you
guys will go ahead and label them or
come to pushing the second so it's thank
wonder or the chief alright people
now the question was ready are those
filled or are they hollow in this case
they will be filled because they're on
the boundaries of the parabola and we
already decided it as the whole
boundaries the parabola is okay because
it satisfies one of these equalities we
believe this one so therefore I'm going
to fill to be the passengers
we already show them you should you
should put to this dictionary video
question this time here yeah so since
this place dotted that might sort of
indicate all I'm not included but don't
know because I've shaded right over the
top of it so therefore the shading kind
of little waves the fact that this part
is thought of its eyes so you don't need
to feel is that line is that's what
you're asking
okay I think it's pretty unambiguous the
areas that I'm referring to
okay just to finish I will also point
out that we went through the time and
effort to grab this and express this and
then drew the intersection right but do
you notice that this area big
intersection area you can also see on
this graph right which part of it is the
relevant part it's the part that I've
shaded twice isn't it you see this in
between plot I've shared it up the top
here because of other travel and I've
shaded it below because the low line so
in fact if I were doing this question
right on the face of it I would not
spend the time to draw extra graphs
because ain't nobody got time for that I
would just draw these two on the same
axes I would go ahead and Shane and I
would notice oh there's a section where
I shade both of them
there's overlapping shading so therefore
that's the intersection that make sense
okay any questions yes not open circles
menendez intersects with
we're about all you need like here if
you just label where that is which is
what- - that's fine
because you can see their third Junction
on other areas it just it just keeps
going on the trail so it doesn't really
do any movement
no you can see there's so much water
we're setting here apart from can you
Tamaki % like that's that's something we
were done with a long time ago this
might be worth I three marks three if
you're lucky cause you see so much
thinking is involved there's a lot of
things you gotta get right to get the
areas
[Music]